[Music]
i never expected that to happen to be
honest with you i'm glad to know that
people still remember me yeah it's true
before i knew
with 14 million views on that tick tock
alone it's clear mason is still a social
media sensation whether there's
a million
or one
no matter what i no matter how many
people are there i would always still
love to sing and perform how does your
family feel about all the success that
you've had over the years they don't
take it for granted they think that this
was a moment that you know was kind of
unexpected
and
i will agree with that
how would you describe life right now
singing is like one of my favorite
things and
working part time at the restaurant here
pretty amazing too so i got two jobs
with you writing music and going down to
nashville who would be the
ideal person that you would love to
collaborate with
like shell
i've always been a rolling stone
a great role model he's a great guy
super nice guy
he's got some great music